اوضاعف في اوكرانيا
والخطوط الاماميه هي صعبه للغايه ال هناك
اعتداءات جديده يتم اعدادها من قبل روسيا
ضد اوكرانيا للهيمنه على البلاد وكذلك
يكون هناك اعاده انشاء لمناطق
التاثير وهذه الامور
بالنسبه
اوكرانيا
الدول التي بامكانها ان تساعد اوكرانيا من
خلال تزويدها بالاسلحه التي تحتاج اليها
لتدافع عن نفسها لتدافع عن الوجود
تتحدث عن عدد من الدبابات الدبابات
الدول الاخرى التي تريد ان تترك نفس
المسلك نامل لان المانيا ستلتحق وتوافق
هذا الامر
يفترض ان يكون هناك اجتماع غدا في
رامشتاين في المانيا همم وهناك ضغوط كبيره
تتعرض لها المانيا حتى تواكب الجهود
الاوروبيه الرميه لتزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
متطوره ماذا تتوقعون من هذا الاجتماع هل
حصلتم على اي تاكيدات من الجانب الالماني
بخصوص هذا الطلب
جيراننا المانيا
لمجموعه الاتصال الخاصه بالحلفاء بخصوصا
الحلفاء
بعض القرارات
على القرارات والزير
لتشارك في هذا التحالف نحن ندعم اوكرانيا
ليس فقط من حيث تزويدها تزويدها عفوا
بالاسلحه وانما كذلك المساعدات الانس
وقبول عدد كبير جدا من اللاجئين الاوكران
في بولندا نتحدث عن ما يزيد عن اثنين
مليون من الاوكرانيين الذين عبروا الحدود
ويعيشون معنا نحن فاجرا نبذل قصار جهدنا
من اج
ل السهر والسلام نريد ان يكون هناك السلام
في اوروبا اريد ان يكون هناك تعاون ما بين
كل الدول
بروسيا ان كانت تريد ان تن هي هذا
الاعتداء الوحشي
شرقا بعد اقتراب من الحدود الروسيه يفترض
ان تكون هذه البلدان اكثر حساسيه في تقييم
موقعها وفي تقييم حرب الدائره في اوكرانيا
بخافه رد الفعل الروسي على تلك البلدان
وهذه البلدان لها ثوابق كبيره مع روسيا
همم التي وردت الاتحاد السوفيتي لماذا
يبدو الموقف البولندي وكانه متقدم جدا في
تسعير هذه الحرب في تاجيل هذه الحرب ودعم
اوكرانيا بكل همم وسائل الدعم بهذه الصوره
هي جزء منها
اه ما بنقار
وسائل الاعلام امريكيه نقلت بالامس عن
مسؤولين امريكيين رفيعي المستوى كما قالت
ان الولايات المتحده فاتت مقتنعه بانه
ينبغي تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه اللازمه
لاستهداف الجسر الرابط بين شبه جزيره
القرم والاراضي الروسيه فيما قد يعد
تصعيدا كبيرا في هذه الحرب موقفكم من هذا
الامر اذا جاءت الدعوه بشكل رسمي او عالمي
من الجانب الامريكي
تحتاج الى الاسلحه وتحتاج كذلك الى همم
مدفعيه بعيده المدى حتى تقوم بعملها على
الطريق بالطريقه الصحيحه انا كنت على
تواصل مع اداره
انهم ليسوا مهتمين باي عمليه تصعيد ليس
مهتمين باستهداف اراضي الروسيه لكن هناك
حرف روسيا قامت بالهجوم على هذه البلاد
ولديهم الحق بان يدافع عن نفسهم وان تكون
لديهم رده فعل نامل ان لا يكون هناك اي
رده فعل هذا الجسر ما بين روسيا وشبه
جزيره القرم هو جزء من اوكرانيا تم بناءه
من قبل روسيا بطريقه غير قانونيه
فعله بذلك عليكم